in just a few more moments
uh yes all right good morning everybody
sorry for the delay we're going to get
going with the executive session on
numerous Senate bills that came before
our committee uh representative hits
foreign
police
[Music]
thank you representative Hicks uh
representative McDonald would you like
to call a role please
I'm in for representative mangaputi my
name is representative tolerski
uh representative Ellen Reid
substituting for representative Al
Holland
present
foreign
representative Brown here representative
Cahill here Dr Davis here
representative here representative
thank you representative Gilman here uh
representative majority here
here thank you ma'am represent Gallagher
here representative Hicks here
representative Reed here representative
priest here and chairman Turca here
thank you Mr Clark we'll go ahead and
get started uh open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 88 relative to
annual dues paid by towns and cities to
town Officers Association
and we have a motion by representative
yokella
thank you Mr chair I move itl
thank you uh representative do we have a
second second thank you representative
Elward representative college would you
like to speak to your motion
um thank you uh Mr chair I am happy to
speak
um I
um am not so in this section this uh
this uh
states that this is for supposed to be
for the education of public officials
um and the
uh and I think that
um we haven't uh I think heard from the
from the associations that they are
unable to train these people uh with the
funds that they are collecting and that
this is the only way that they can
achieve that
um because I think that there's other
ways of achieving like you know people
attending uh they could they could
require some nominal fee for for people
to to go to the trainings and and be
able to fund those trainings that way I
don't I don't necessarily know that they
need to um
uh increase the amount of funds going
through on memberships
um to discharge their duty of of
educating these public officials there's
also the concern that
um in the statute there is a requirement
that each of the towns pay these dues to
these associations
and that increasing the amount of not
just one Association but all of these
associations for the potential up to
fifty dollars is
actually over doubling the um State
mandate that be expended on these
associations and you know as as it uh
seems to me to be an increase of of
unfended mandate from the state to the
order of maybe 100 or 150 dollars a town
and and not necessarily sure that all of
that money 100 of that money is going to
the education
um and not other other uh Avenues so for
those reasons I support the itl motion
foreign
representative stavis
would just like to note uh with respect
to this bill that we have had similar
bills that have similar amounts of
increases for similar activities and we
have passed those
further comments or questions
representative Gallagher
um
so
one thing
so this one the hearing we didn't really
get a chance to um
hear from
the prime sponsor much about and that
would have been useful
um
I mean
I think some of the the point
um
representative yokelo raised about not
having heard from certain people
is a decent one but that to me would
signal more to me that we ought to
retain it rather than itl it
um I don't necessarily have any
opposition to the bill on principle
um I just wish we could have gotten some
more information about it
further comments or questions
representative 11.
thank you Mr chair
um after reading the bill and giving it
some thought and listening to
representative yokella and
representative Gallagher what comes to
my mind is the inflation that all of us
are facing and the
prices of everything going up
and raising the amount available
to have someone join an organization and
then benefit from the information the
organization
can provide
seems to me to be totally worth it in
2023 terms so I would support an auto
pass of this bill
thank you
thank you representative representative
power
thank you Mr chairman
so um the the twenty dollar cap was
established in 1977 and to my knowledge
there has not been a bill to raise it
and that's quite a that's quite a long
time
so I would support this increase from 20
to 50 if it was optional but clearly on
line four of the bill statute it's it's
an unfunded State mandate and I'm um
unwilling
to increase an unfunded State mandate so
I'm going to vote itl based on for those
reasons
thank you representative uh
representative Gallagher
um so also looking at our notes I note
that we have an amendment here from
representative yokella so I was
I I would like to know
um why we are going straight to itl
before
discussing the amendment
representative of your color would you
like to answer that question
I am not sure that I
I think that I would support the bill
uh as amended but I'm not confident that
such an amendment would be able to pass
and so I would I wouldn't vote for it
without an amendment and so that's why I
I chose to go with itl first
but if it if the itls failed I'd be
happy to put it forward with the
amendment
representative status
question of the chair
um a concern over whether an amendment
will pass or not it is adequate
justification for not bringing forth the
amendment
the maker of the amendment chose not to
put it forward if as he said if this itl
fails he could certainly bring forth
that Amendment
um so as I said I mean as the maker of
the motion it's my choice to make the
motion that I that I choose to make
right that I don't have to make any
specific motion just because I prepared
this I you know I talk to people and I'm
not sure just for the expediency of time
uh that it would pass and so therefore I
just skip right to where I thought the
eventual
um the bill was going to eventually go
in an expedience of time so thank you
thank you representative representative
priest
thank you Mr chairman I am too going to
vote against italing this bill
the three individuals of the town that
this is targeting they provide very
valuable services
to their residents and businesses
and I think raising their membership
from 25 to 50
it's an it's a no-brainer I mean
especially if it's been
um the 25 was established in 1977.
um as reported by the deputy so I I
don't think this is an issue we need to
keep them up to speed on the current
laws and regulations and and and
mechanisms that can make their jobs
easier in these very challenging times
thank you
thank you representative
representative Guthrie
thank you very much I I feel pretty much
the same way the only thing we're doing
is uh changing the the amount of the
dues so the the concerns that have been
voiced uh
I'm not going to be really in the bill
the bill is only when he's changing the
amount of money we're already committed
to do all the any of the other things
that are already in the the law so I
can't i.tl it I have I would have to
vote
ought to pass if a motion is made
besides the bill is submitted by my
senator
thank you representative Guthrie any
further comments or questions uh
microphone representative Guthrie
thank you
um
seeing no more I'm just going to make a
quick comment on it and re reiterate uh
what representative yukela and
representative power talked about
originally I thought this was a very
simplistic bill just it's money but it
goes beyond money and it goes to the
issue of where that money goes and it is
a mandate
line four
um where it talks about it says each
town and City shall pay annually it
doesn't give him the option it says
shell over on six It also says such
amounts shall be due annual membership
so I think that uh sometimes it's not
just about the dollar value yes there
has been inflation but in this it's as
much or more about
um I don't want to if it's a process or
whatever you want to call it but uh so I
would agree at this point on the itel
motion
further comments questions clerk uh
representative hold on representative
thank you Mr chair and thanks for your
comments
um
I understand that mandates can be
overbearing
sometimes one-sided sometimes unclear I
think that mandating that town officials
have the education that they can receive
from
local organizations that can provide it
is worth a mandate in my opinion thank
you
thank you for the comments seeing none
clerk call the roll please
okay this is uh SB 88 and the motion is
itl uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes no representative Salas
yes
representative Keller
representative Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown
yes
representative Cahill oh no
Representative stavis no
Representative no
representative tree 11. no
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
Representative teleski no
representative Gallagher
no
representative Hicks no
representative Reed no
representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
the itl fails uh seven yeses and 13
notes thank you Miss clerk
representative yokella uh would you like
to propose an amendment thank you yes I
would like to propose amendment uh
2023- uh one seven one one-h
I'm happy to speak to them women do we
have a second
representative uh to 11 seconds
would you like to speak to uh your
Amendment thank you yes absolutely
so
um in this statute as a uh
read it it says that this is
um
to ensure that there is education of
public officials in in tax problems and
other matters pertaining to the proper
and efficient discharge of their duties
and
um maybe there is a a
reason to increase the annual membership
whether that to
um
increase the amount of Education that
goes to the
um these Town officials we didn't hear
that but maybe that is what is necessary
but um
under the the way that that the law is
currently it this money can be
diverted away from that education into
other other parts
um specifically uh
in uh it can be transferred into
accounts that uh are are regulated by
RSA 15 5 Roman 2.
which is accounts that fund lobbying and
not education
and so all this is trying to do is to
say yes if you want to increase you want
to have this this money for dues it
needs to go towards your your operations
of your uh of your uh Association or for
actual training not not go towards
lobbying if you want to do that it
should be additional money on top of the
dues or whatever we're not requiring
that these local uh
these local state agencies these are the
only ones I believe that are required
that these local municipalities
are required to fund the ones like nhma
and stuff like that are optional but
these are required and so these need to
be for their stated purpose for their
operations and for the education of
these Town officials and nothing more or
nothing
out uh that would be uh considered
lobbying I think that's outside of that
that we should be mandating the towns to
do or you know to fund so thank you
thank you representative comments
represent uh priests
yes will the speaker the the last
speaker and the sponsor of this bill
answer a question that I have
he may answer it if why don't you state
your question and we'll see if he wants
to answer the question is he alluded to
the fact that there was all this
information out there that towns are
using their membership monies for
lobbying and I haven't seen that and so
I'm just curious
where this is coming from and where the
information is thank you
do respond
thank you I'm I'm happy to comment and
say that this is if
if as you surmise that none of their
membership dues were being used for
lobbying then this would have no effect
right this would only have effect if
they were trying to transfer some of
their membership dues away from their
operating expenses and their actual Duty
which is to train these Town officials
and moving that money into lobbying
efforts and so I'm just trying to create
a wall there and say if the state has
come in and say you have to be a member
of this organization and you have to get
trained because it's important that you
get trained so that we have Equitable
Taxation and all of this stuff
that if the state is doing that mandate
then we make sure the money goes where
it's supposed to go which is education
and specifically stated in that in the
Bill thank you
thank you represent uh representative
majority
thank you Mr chair
um I'm I'm opposed to the amendment on
on the grounds that I've heard because I
think that if there are organizations
that also do Lobby I'm not gonna not
gonna argue that point but if they do
lobby but also provide training
um nhma for instance that name has come
up provides all kinds of different
training where maybe now that these
organizations can't participate in that
or can't benefit from it I just wonder
if that kind of confusion may arise by
adding this language and for that reason
I would be opposed but I you know tell
me that I'm wrong and that's fine
thank you thank you representative uh we
had representative Guthrie next actually
and then representative
thank you I just like to say that as I
said I think before that lobbying is not
a duty word no and that it's it is in
fact sometimes education
so I wouldn't
not support the amendment because I
don't have any concern about that area
representative Reed
thank you and and I appreciate the
opportunity to speak although I'm a
substitute so not that I don't trust my
colleague uh representative yokella but
I did look up the RSA to which
um the amendment refers and I'll just
read it very directly
um so it's a Prohibition on state funds
or in this case would be the town funds
to Lobby or attempt to influence
legislation participate in political
activity or contribute funds to any
entity engaged in these activities as a
person who has
basically cut my political teeth on
campaign Finance reform
um I think it's extremely important that
we make sure taxpayer funds don't go to
lobbying lobbying itself is not a dirty
word because it can be education but
paid lobbying paid lobbying is quite
different and to use taxpayer funds to
lobby for a legislative outcome when
those taxpayers didn't have a say in
that is quite problematic to me on a
number of levels so for that reason I
will be supporting the amendment
further comments
we represent oh
representative uh yokella thank you I
just wanted to kind of comment on
representative manageri's concerns about
um so this would not affect an inch May
in any way
um they so this is only for these
specific
um associations that are mandated that
we join in the state right this wouldn't
uh
um nhma can put 100 of their Municipal
you know uh uh uh
um dues yes dues to lobbying if they so
choose the the this statute is is for
being making sure that our town officers
are trained and educated
um and that is what these dues are
supposed to facilitate and that is the
whole section of this statute if they
wanted to do additional things oven be
over and beyond that I think that should
be optional for those Town
um uh towns people to be able to pay for
that or not right that this is a state
Mandate of what we are saying is the
bare minimum that the that the um those
towns do and so since this is a mandate
um from the state saying you have to do
this you have to join this
um that I think gets a little bit
different than just saying like no we're
not going to allow it I think that you
know they could raise money in other
ways by just asking or saying like Hey
we're gonna
um you know charge for for like
Municipal accounting uh we we pay dues
to nhma and my local
um
town but then when we go to trainings we
actually have to pay additional
sometimes additional money to go to that
training right and so there's no reason
that these other organizations couldn't
do that and raise the money from that
and that could get diverted into
lobbying all of that is possible right
it's not forbidding any of that I'm just
saying that um you know the bare minimum
that the state has said is a mandate
we're not we should not divert that
money into to lobbying efforts that's
that's the only
concern kind of thing hope that
clarifies kind of the intent thank you
did I see representative L word's hand
up no okay represent power
thank you Mr chairman so relative to
this amendment one I I would like to
point out that the statute in front of
us
um 31 8
relative to the town offices Association
it's very clear that this is mandatory
because it says shall whereas with
regard to dues paid to organizations
such as the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and the New Hampshire School
Board Association those
um
associations
those relationships and um in the paying
of the dues to those latter
organizations is optional there are
towns that choose not to pay those dues
and therefore not to have an association
with those organizations so I just want
to point that out
perhaps representative Gallagher
um
so as to whether this is mandatory or
not
um
so yes it does say shell paper
It also says the the amount page shall
not exceed so that to me seems to apply
that can be any amount less than that as
long as they pay something like they
could theoretically just pay one cent or
something and because I would be paying
something and it would be an amount that
would not exceed either of those so I I
don't or they could just if they're
already paying 20 they could just keep
paying 20 and
um yeah I I would see that as keeping
in in with it so yeah I I don't see them
as I don't see this as mandating
fifty dollars I see it as
um
yeah shall not exceed fifty dollars
further comments or questions
representative stavis
I guess this may be a devil's advocate
question or comment but if this is
perceived to be an unfunded mandate
wouldn't it be an unfunded mandate at
any level at all
not to exceed five cents
then why are we arguing about the edges
foreign
further comments questions
representative power thank you Mr
chairman a question that I had and I I
did not I I don't recall because I
didn't note it in my notes from the
hearing is if anybody could inform me as
to how the the do's or the fees get set
is it true that each organization
sets the fee and then in turn the
municipality pays it or is it a donation
up to 20 or 50 dollars
representative Cahill
thanks for letting me speak
well I can't speak to how the
legislative body was thinking in 1977
when they when when they put this in but
what I can say is I think it would cost
the taxpayers a lot more money to have
to pay for programs to teach these
clerks and teach these people so I think
they're getting beneficial information
and if we had to run that program it
would cost us a lot more I think I think
this is an affordable program and that
could be why only certain groups were
mandated to be a part of it because tax
laws change and they need to be educated
on tax laws right we can't just assume
they're going to know that information
and I see this as ain't
um a way that we can keep in line with
what we were doing and and it would cost
the taxpayers a lot more to do it a
different way
thank you representative
representative uh Reed thank you and um
just to be clear we're we're discussing
the amendment currently which so not the
uh merits of the underlying Bill whether
the limit is or what's mandate and
what's not mandated
um so to bring it back to the underlying
bill I wanted to add one thing to my
previous comment which is
um whilst campaign Finance reform is
technically different than lobbying
reform the the intent is uh largely the
same which is to make sure that we have
a government that functions and
represents the people and I just want to
add that on the federal level again this
is campaign and not lobbying reform but
on the federal level it is so extreme
that if you're a federal employee or
many federal employees you receive money
as part of your job as a federal
employee from the government
by the Hatch Act you are not allowed to
even have a campaign sign in your own
yard
so again speaking to the actual
Amendment before us I think that the
merits of it to separate
um the taxpayer funds from lobbying is
important
thank you
seeing no more comments I will say
I never expected such
an extended debate over a one-word one
one number change in a bill I've also
been requested to take a two-minute
recess
um by this three-minute Recess by the
senior member of the minority party so
we will just everybody remain seated
we'll be right back three minute recess
okay everybody
take your seats we're gonna keep
pressing on
I want a prize
okay everybody back
foreign
seeing no more comments on that
amendment can we call the role on the
amendment please
okay this is a SB 88 and the amendment
number is 2023 1711h
Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
collect votes no representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Howard yes representative
Brown
yes representative Cahill
no
Representative stavis no
representative
no representative 11. yeah
yeah representative Gilman no
representative majority no
Representative no
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative priest
are we I'm sorry I got ahead of myself
representative Reed yes
okay I representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
motion passes 11 to 9.
uh representative yokella would you like
to make a motion
ought to pass as amended
thank you second
so seconded representative Reed seconds
further discussion
representative priests
thank you being none
will be clerk call the world
for just a minute Mr chairman
yep
foreign
Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
yeah click votes yes representative
Salas yes
representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Alward yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes represents Davis yes representative
yes representative Trey Levin
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Reed yes representative priest yes and
Mr chairman yes
motion passes 20 to zero
thank you Miss clerk uh is there any
opposition to this going on the consent
calendar
seeing none
consent calendar it will be
represent of yokella
you're going to write a brief or
we'll discuss it afterwards how's that
all right
that close is the exact session on
Senate Bill 88 and we will open up the
executive session on SB 111 relative to
the Town Council manager form of local
government
representative power do you have a
motion
would you like to introduce some
Amendment thank you Mr chairman I would
like to offer the committee Amendment
2023-1631h
thank you do we have a second on that
representative uh Davis
seconds
representative power I'd like to speak
to your men yes thank you Mr chairman so
um as you recall during the the hearing
on this bill
it was um noted that the language the
grandma needed to be um fixed to further
clarify the the bill
and in
in going about that a number of other
issues were identified with the bill
itself
and the grammar fixes that were being
made so
um
the problem well we understand and we we
know that under 49b a town May adopt a
charter that provides for an optional
form of legislative body and in 1991
when
RSA 49d was adopted there were at that
time through only three optional forms
of a legislative body under D3 that was
the Town Council the budgetary town
meeting and the representative town
meeting
as noted by Roman numerals one two and
three and then sometimes later two
additional optional forms of legislative
body were added and that's 1A and 2A
and the problem was is that they were
not properly referenced back in D colon
2.
and so Senate Bill 111 the whole purpose
of it was to clarify
um these sorts of things
so um to speak to the amendment itself
if you look at lines seven and eight
those words in bold they were they're
there to make clear that a town May
adopt a charter
with one of the five optional forms of
legislative body that is enumerated
under our 49d colon 3. the remainder of
line eight lines eight and then nine and
part in in ten that is the whole intent
of the bill is to make clear that towns
that adopt a charter
under
um D colon 3 Roman numeral one which is
the Town Council
form of option optional form of
legislative body that they shall have
the same powers and authorities as a
city council and that was the whole
purpose of the bill so that's why that's
there then you also see
um
changes to the last sentence which is in
lines 10 and 11. as you can see this
form is struck and it had to be struck
in part of the problem with the original
bill was is that with the addition of
the amended words
it just didn't make sense so what that
last change in lines 10 and 11 does is
it makes it clear that this form refers
to a budgetary town meeting
um under Roman numeral two
and then it just the rest of the text is
is the same
so I hope that I made that clear
okay questions
from the committee seeing none
read
ask the click to call a role on the
amendment
yeah yeah
there we go sorry again
SP 111 adopt the amendment is 1631h
Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
correct votes yes representative
lasalles
okay
uh represent your color
no
I'm sorry one more time I didn't hear
you I'm sorry no no
representative Kelly yes
representative Elwood
yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes representative yes
representative yes representative tree
eleven yeah
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Reed yes representative
priest yes
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion passes 18 to 1.
thank you Mr clerk excellent okay
and uh do we have a motion
representative power on octopass as
amended
um thank you Mr chairman I would like to
make the motion
on Senate Bill 111 ought to pass as
amended
and seconded by Representatives Davis
further discussion
seeing none will ask the clerk to call
the rule
SBI 111 ought to pass is amended
by Sherman power yes
represent Guthrie
clerk votes yes represent okay
uh Representative no
representative Kelly yes representative
Elwood yes representative Brown
yes representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis
yes representative
yes representative yeah
yeah representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
uh representative yes
representative Gallagher
yes
representative Hicks has representative
Reed yes
representative priest yes and Mr
chairman yes
uh OTP is amended passes 18-1
thank you Miss Clark it's uh any
opposition to the consent calendar
seeing none representative power
committee report thank you look closely
here uh executive session on SB 111.
and we'll go ahead and open up the
executive session on Senate Bill 110
relative uh no yes 110 relative to
residency status
and on that I will uh
introduce a
recognize myself for an amendment to SB
and that will be Amendment
2023-1585 H do we have a second on that
I'll second that representative Brown
um seconds it uh just speaking briefly
to it the the original Bill itself quite
honestly brought had a lot of uh
a lot of issues in my opinion on it and
what I've tried to do in the amendment
is if you look at the I took item two
now is basically what was item number
Roman numeral five before
and have
placed that in as a basically a
recommendation
when temporary assistance is provided to
residents of the municipalities they may
communicate coordinate assistant options
to include reimbursement from that
person's Municipality of origin and that
was an addition made in the original
Bill the other issue the other
I'm just speaking to the amendment for
now so that's all I'll say on that
other firm further comments questions on
that representative
yeah I just have questions on Roman
numerals two three and four
of the bill the underlying Bill and I'm
assuming the ear Amendment does not
change those
it eliminates those it eliminates those
yep
for the comments or questions
yes thank you very much this is the
question to the sponsor of the amendment
uh could you kind of give us your ideas
why you're proposing this amendment and
the purpose of it
um the purpose of the amendment is to
eliminate
what I consider uh poorly constructed
poorly written
other pieces of the original Bill I know
I'm speaking to the amendment but items
two three and four there's a lot of uh
discussion on those when we
held the the hearing
issues about residency impacts on voting
um
30 days resonance status put in here
consecutive 30 days here or there it was
not in my opinion just poorly poorly
written in it quite honestly my intent
was to recommend an itl on the entire
bill but in in
I guess the word would be showing some
good will to the sponsors
um I went and
used item five Roman numeral five which
now becomes item uh two Roman numeral
two so that's basically the gist of it
for the comments questions see none
that's the clerk to call the room
SB 110 adopt Amendment 2023 1585 h
uh by Sherman power yes representative
Guthrie
collect votes yes representative
lasalles yes
uh represent your killer yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Elwood yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes
Representative stavis no
Representative no
representative tree eleven no
representative Gilman no
representory no
uh Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks nope
representative Reed no
representative priests no
and Mr chairman yes
uh 10 to 10 the motion kills thank you
Mr Clark uh Is there further motion
representative
Davis
make a motion about to pass
is that motion second representative
majority seconds discussion
seeing none
once the clerk is ready we will call the
roll on that
you do
okay uh OTP on SBE 110 uh Vice chairman
of power no
representative Guthrie
collect votes no Representative lasalles
no
representative Kelly
representative Kelly no
representative Howard no
representative Brown
no representative Cahill
no
Representatives Davis yes
representative yes representative Trail
Evans yes representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative
yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Reed yes
representative priest yes
and Mr chairman no
10 10.
okay so that motion fails representative
power do you have a motion
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to make a
motion of retain on Senate bill 110.
you have a second on that
I'll check that Mr represent Brown
seconds the motion would you like to
speak to that
thank you Mr chairman
um I've I just my feeling is that there
was Amendment you know that was
introduced in the language in the bill
as written is is
um
very confusing and and problematic and
um I think that I feel that this bill
um
needs could benefit from from further
um work
and so therefore I would like to see it
retained thank you for the comments
seeing none unless the clerk when he's
ready to call the role
uh sb110 the motion is to retain uh Vice
chairman power yes
Corruption of Guthrie yeah
click votes yes representative Salas yes
representative Keller no
representative Kelly
representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis no
representative Tatro no
representative tree 11. no
no representative Gilman no
representative majority no
uh Representative no
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no representative
Reed no representative Priest No
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion fails 11 to 9. thank you Miss
Clark so this bill will go to the floor
without recommendation
um
I'll do it okay
representative majority uh majority
still not 100 here
um
after seeing all those Cathedrals with
my name on them yes
um minority opinion who would like
uh representative power Maybe
no
okay uh we'll we'll figure out who will
The Minority Report will be
and with that we'll close the executive
session on hsb110
okay uh next up Senate Bill 222 relative
to the definition of broadband
infrastructures as a revenue producing
facility eligible for municipal revenue
bonds open the executive session on that
and would like I would like to uh
introduce amendment number 20 23 1709 h
do we have a second
like the second that Mr chairman the
representative Brown seconds that
Amendment and I'll speak briefly to it I
this was one I apologize I know it came
to everybody late last night I tried to
get it to you as soon as I can uh
yesterday afternoon OLS didn't finish it
till then
um and I want to explain exactly why I
wanted uh this amendment if you look on
line nine the Bold
and the state shall not be financially
liable for a default of such bonds the
reason I added that in is these
when reviewing the Senate hearing
the one of the sponsors himself actually
had concerns about the default and the
liability under this
adding the communications District
and what I wanted to do was
call it what you want lay down a marker
that this committee for future
legislators actually understood that
there was always the potential
for a default of such bonds
um
the odds of that happening are probably
slim the difference here is in the past
these bonds have been for regional water
districts and
municipalities we are now adding in very
High uh technical
broadband
where the technology can change
extremely rapidly
during the testimony on this bill I
asked the and again this was the same
concerns the senator had I asked you
know how long did he think
Broadband with wires is not going to be
when will it be superseded by either
Wireless or
or satellite and the answer was well
probably around three to five years
we had a bill
last year in finance that expended over
40 million dollars to hardwire the North
country
and when you averaged it out it was at
to the tune of almost twenty thousand
dollars per
household that they were gonna wire up
which is a ridiculous amount of money
for technology that could be changing in
an instant
um
satellite
exists now
and in three years who knows what
they'll be doing uh with satellite and
or again Wireless itself so again I
wanted to put a a marker down that this
committee was actually considering the
possibility of a default I know in the
previous sentence existing language that
talks about the pledge of faith and
credit that's different than a default
of the bonds so that's my reasoning
behind the added language
thank you
comments and questions representative
majority
thank you Mr chair
um I certainly appreciate that you
wanted to as your words lay that marker
down because it provides the kind of
fiscal protection that I think is is
important Financial Protection is
important but the question is
um was the language vetted by Bond
Council so that we have the assurances
that this doesn't trigger something that
they can't that the towns cannot or that
wow
uh so this doesn't trigger something uh
that cannot be met
on my watch
again on my watch
and answering a question briefly the
answer is no I did not
thank you representative
Mr chairman I did speak with the New
Hampshire Municipal Association before
the session and they did indicate to me
that it would not cause a problem for
the bond a change in the procedure but
not a problem for the bonding
thank you representative Brown
are there further comments or questions
representative McDonald
thank you Mr chairman
this uh whole process has been going on
for about the past six years or so we're
trying to get some help
so folks can get internet they'll put
their residents up in the north country
and this is another not going to use the
word tool but something that's going to
allow these businesses and citizens of
the North Country to get some internet
connections
it's going to allow them to as a group
borrow money as bonds uh I've been on
this committee since I started back in
2018 and I've never seen this particular
wordage stuck into an amendment where it
was directed particularly at water and
the uh and the internet as far as the uh
the internet changing yeah it does
change it's probably going to change a
lot and it's probably going to be a
couple years before uh
this service gets going but it's not
enough us to decide that no we're not
going to give these people the
opportunity to get some funding to uh
get the internet it's up to them to
decide how they want to proceed once
they get the money and then ask you
folks not to support the amendment thank
you
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair I have the same
concerns uh I know we've talked about
the
um the life span of broadband hardwired
out into the remote communities
and um
within my own town which is fairly
compact we still have Broadband lines we
also have wireless and we have uh um
satellite Communications but we also
have even with all the antenna that have
been attached to buildings and and
erected we still have
empty spots where people cannot
communicate including my fire department
um so I I don't want to count on the
improvements to those others
Technologies
um
I think there needs to be a solid
connection to the World Wide Web thank
you
thank you I just want to remind that we
are speaking actually to the amendment
here not to the actual bill itself the
bill itself
um
yep thank you representative
uh thank you Mr chair I would just like
to point out that the wording of the
amendment May in fact contravene
existing law
where in RSA 33 it says the Govern the
governor and Council meaning the
executive Council May award an
unconditional State guarantee of the
principle of an interest on bonds issued
under RSA 33.
um
with if we adopt this amendment
that effectively prevents the governor
and Council from doing what's written in
law currently
thank you
for the comments
seeing none unless the clerk
Representatives
yes I will be voting against this
amendment also
um
Broadband is is crucial for our
community especially in the rural
portions of the state but also those
pockets
in our existing communities that
presented a priests are we talking about
we're talking about the amendment and
anything that is added to the bill that
might jeopardize
municipalities from doing this
than I would be opposed thank you thank
you for the comments
Mr Clark will ask you to call the roll
thank you Mr chairman
yeah
okay uh sp222 adopt the amendment
2023-1709
uh Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes no representative lasalles
yes
representative yukela yes representative
Kelly yes
representative Edward yes representative
Brown yes
representative Cahill
yes
Representatives Davis no
representative Tatro no
representation 11 no
representative Gilman no
representative jewelry no
Representative teleski no representative
Gallagher
uh no
representative Hicks no
representative Reed no
representative priests no
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion fails nine to eleven thank you
Mr clerk do we have another motion
Representatives Davis I move ought to
pass
and do we have a second representative
priests
would you like to speak to your motion
I think
thank you Mr chair
um
I feel that the underlying bill is a
good bill and one that is long overdue
um I know people in parts of the state
who are unable to access Broadband in
any way shape or form
and it while it is true that the
technology changes quickly other forms
of technology are also changing quickly
so I don't think that that's an issue I
think people are getting used to things
changing quickly
and the the germane issue here is that
municipalities need to have the
authority and the ability under our laws
to um to bond this process
representative lasalles
yes a question of uh representative
stavis
it's my understanding correct me if I'm
wrong that everyone has access to
satellite internet communications is
that correct
it is partially correct it's actually
not correct
um I have relatives who live in the town
of Freedom New Hampshire which is
up there and on the border with Maine
they don't they can't get access to
starlink which is the Tesla uh satellite
system there's no broadband access there
there's just it's a desert it's an
internet desert and they have been
waiting and waiting and waiting and not
just in freedom but in the entire Lake
Area there they've been waiting for
years for the state to help them get
access to the internet which is now
become a public utility you can't live
without it really and without success so
starlink not available regular internet
not available a Communications Wasteland
thank you representative uh I
you expanded my field of knowledge there
because I was under the understanding
that if you could look up into the sky
you could get some sort of satellite
communication
but you've corrected me on that
represent representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman and I'm a little
confused what is what is startling
um
no no not no representative
what is it um so aside from the the uh
information that the ranking member
provided about potential gaps in
satellites like starlink
uh uh that are provided I can tell you
and I'm sure maybe this is not the
common experience of many of the members
of this committee but as a renter uh
someone who rents somebody else's
property or somebody in an apartment
building you cannot put up a satellite
dish very frequently almost never can
put up a satellite dish so no you do not
have access to satellite
representative Brown
Mr chairman just for the committee I do
live in the Wasteland and we do have
access to Satellite Communication in
that area Karen Carroll County because
that's what I initially had at my home
but I do now have regular internet and I
do support the bill overall so
representative Elwood
thank you Mr chairman I too have
a satellite internet
and television
and I don't
um have any problems with that so I
support the bill
for the comments are quite represent
kale
I would like to ask a question of
Representative Davies
could you tell us that RSA that you've
quoted a little while ago for 35
whatever it was I just it wasn't fast
enough oh dear
just the one we're amending it's okay
long
for the questions or comments or
questions uh comments
seeing none I'm gonna make one um
one of the issues I found
we we continually hear about the housing
crisis and the cost of uh housing that
continually goes up and up and up I it
was interesting to hear a comment made
by someone given testimony last week
that by uh
getting Broadband to everybody's houses
that would raise that actually raises
the prices of real estate which is kind
of contrary to the housing crisis
problem that we're trying to solve but
anyway uh we asked that the clerk call
the role please
okay uh SB 222 uh
OTP
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller
no
representative Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes
representative Cahill yes representative
stavis yes
representative
yes
representative 11. yeah representative
Gilman
yes representative majority yes
representative toolski yes
representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Reed yes
representative priests yes
and Mr chairman no
motion passes
18 to 2. thank you Miss clerk is there
any opposition to the consent calendar
seeing none uh committee reports
all right representative Ms Davis will
be doing the committee report on that
um
can we just take a break yes
um we are going to take uh
15 minute break the clerk needs to
gather some more paperwork we
've had a lot of uh
roll calls so we've got 15 minutes
everybody be back at uh 10 after please
thank you
okay I think everybody's back
I'm waiting for that
all right so we're going to open up the
next executive session with
representative Brown go
yes yes I see that okay I move
um wait a minute what
all right we'll open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 78 relative to
subdivision regulations
on the completion of improvements
I understand there is a an amendment to
be introduced and I recognize
representative power thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to offer the committee
Amendment 2023-1627h
thank you is there a second on that
representative Buzz Davis
representative power would you like to
speak to the amendment thank you Mr
chairman so
um this amendment reflects
the input that this um
that representative infantine
heard during the hearing
so
just to highlight
what the amendment does is that on page
two
the there's a sentence that was removed
um
because the the original Bill the
language was
um
somewhat convoluted
so it just it clarifies things and
um eliminates may not require and and
states it
positively and straightforward and
secondly
there was another sentence that was
completely removed
and that's the sentence that had the the
word onerous in it
and I had commented that that was um
very vague and subjective
and
additionally as you can see through
throughout the number of days has been
increased
um in a few lines to give more time to
um react to the business and that's
required within that line of Statute for
example going from 20 to 30 business
days on line nine on page two and
um the change was made similarly in
lines 12 and 16 again to give more time
um
I
this is this bill is important and it
reflects a lot of
um collaboration with the stakeholders
and uh
working also closely with nhma so I
would um hope that people would support
the amendment
representative representative Gallagher
um so I believe so it looks like we have
two separate amendments here
um so does
just to clarify about the one we're on
1627h so that's meant to supersede the
other one 1429 each I take it um and
um basically be an improvement over that
is that correct to be clear we never
adopted that first one we were the only
thing that we've heard is the actual
bill itself so
uh rep infantine did bring that one and
gave it to us but we never acted on it
so this one here would be the first
amendment that we actually Act
act on
representative priest
Mr chairman I will also be
supporting this amendment because I
think it does offer some clarification
of the questions that we had and we
heard
at our last
public hearing
and with that I would be fully in
support of Bill HSB 78 thank you thank
you for the comments questions
seeing none will ask the quote sorry
about that
you have to reach out a little further I
can't see you now I representation
thank you Mr chairman
um
I have a question about the
a the reasoning
for this change
and the only thing I could
see is the
it's to help out the contractors but yet
it takes away
and the assurances
to a municipality
for retaining any money for uh
improvements that are
work that hadn't been
done in a
uh
in the proper methods like when they're
building the roads and so forth I've
I've seen them come through and put
blocks underneath the
sewer lines and then just backfill and
then
a couple of years down the road the
town's liable for it
why it's the
the build seems to be protecting the
contractors rather than protecting the
municipalities
is is that is that a correct
assumption on my part
I'm not sure what the Assumption your
assumption is I think you'd have to
decide that one on yourself I don't
believe that's the case
okay
further points uh comments
seeing none of that as the clerk to
Colorado
SB 78 adopt Amendment
2023-1627 h
uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes representative lasalles
yes
representative Keller yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes
representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis yes
Representative titro no
representative chair 11 yeah
yeah representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative chairski yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes
representative Reed yes
representative priest yes
and Mr chairman yes
uh motion passes 19 to 1.
thank you Mr clerk any opposition to the
consent calendar
that was the amendment oh sorry about
that I had it myself uh further motions
represented power
the chairman I'd like to move
ought to pass as amended on house Senate
bill 78.
is there a second
representative lasalles uh sorry
representative osalis
I'll second that all right we gotcha uh
further comments I guess the amendment
itself is the bill so
representative Park I'd just like to
make one comment that again this is an
important bill and that substantial time
and effort has been
um
spended on on this bill like I said with
this with the stakeholders and it it's a
reasonable
I guess compromise if you will and the
end result is that it will
make it more
efficient or provide the the ability for
home builders to provide housing for the
citizens of New Hampshire so I would um
hope that the committee would support
ought to pass as amended
thank you for the comments
representative
yes I will be supporting SB 782
having served as a planner both in the
public and private sectors I know the
games that are played
um by some people regarding development
applications and this kind of results
into thousands of dollars of penalties
and I think this really kind of
clarifies
who does what what time and where and
what's expected
and it kind of levels the playing field
and I think that's important if we move
on and try to address our housing crisis
thank you thank you for the comments
questions
seeing none unless the clerked collar
rule
SB 78
otpa
by Sherman power yes representative
Guthrie
click votes yes representative lasalles
yes representative your cowboy
yes representative Kelly yes
representative Alward
yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill
represents Davis
yes
representative teacher
no
representative tree 11.
representative Gilman yes representative
majority yes
yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Reed yes representative preach yes and
Mr chairman yes
uh motion passes 19 to 1.
thank you Mr clerk now is there any
opposition to the consent calendar
I see none it will go on the consent
calendar representative power will be
writing the committee reports
thank you
that closes the executive session on HB
78 and we'll go ahead and press on
Senate Bill 47
establishing a commission to study
barriers to increase density of
residential development in New Hampshire
um I'd like to go ahead and introduce a
Amendment 2023
1677h that was sent to everybody about a
week maybe a little more than a week ago
uh committee email
and is there do I have a second on that
second that Mr chairman representative
Brown is the second
um
so I'm going to start out by saying that
we were
encouraged at the beginning of this
session chairs and vice chairs and
individuals that um
stop the commissions
we have a commission to study
commissions we have I think north of 250
different commissions that the speaker
and his assistants spend months actually
Staffing every time there's a
a new legislature in session I don't
believe they've completed at this time
most of those commissions don't meet
a lot of times they don't do what
they're supposed to but yet they're
still out there and he has been
asked us to
stop with the commissions
my my personal thought
on this
as we don't need it we have a special
committee
on housing
um
we've got this committee
and
when you look at the the sponsors of the
bills the majority of them are our
Senators
and it would almost appear that this has
been sent over for us to
uh I'm not going to go down that road
um
so in in the amendment
um since the majority of the sponsors
are Senators uh one of the changes that
I I made was the number of members of
the Senate that would be on the
committee
they they uh heavily loaded it to being
members of the House
and I've brought that back they had it
at a two and six ratio I brought it back
and said
you have it you have three members and
we have five
um a couple other minor changes here and
there the the biggest one I want to
point out was
to me this was lacking the original
commission bill was lacking in what I
would consider fiscal oversight that's
what I care about is the fiscal side
and uh 2B which starts down on line 31
talks about a lot of those and that's is
the the impacts that the development
including that development
would be to look at school enrollment
and property values the next page it
talks about traffic maintenance erode
public works department Staffing
increases in Municipal Services fire
police all that trash removal water
sources
and
that was lacking in the original uh
bill sv47
um there was also one other change down
at the bottom
where was it I changed the date on the
when they would first have to report it
it brought it up a little closer so they
would have a little bit more time
afterwards to to do to act
um honestly
without the amendment I'll be vote I
would vote against it only because again
my my thought process is if there's a
group of individuals who want to
accomplish something you don't need a
commission to do it you've got a group
of senators
or if I had a a bill or something that I
wanted to do
I'd gather the people that I thought
could get me there and come up with the
the plan
and
put a bill forward
um I I I'm not a fan of pawning off
work on commissions
and then having our poor
uh
speaker of the house and their folks
trying to staff these things and then
the
the meetings not being of much value in
the end so I I would ask that you
support the amendment if the Amendments
passes I will support it as a whole
otherwise I will not so thank you uh
representative power
thank you Mr chairman um I appreciate
this this amendment because as you
recall during the hearing I did ask the
um
I believe it was the Prime sponsor I
asked someone I don't recall who but I
was trying to get get to the point that
part of the the the scope or one of the
focuses of this commission was to study
the impacts of development and I asked
the question in so on page two line
eight of the bill
one of the focuses is to study the
impacts of development and that they
specifically point to school enrollments
and property values so I appreciate the
this amendment in that it IT addresses
what I was trying to get at and the
answer was
um I said what other Municipal
um
what other things or resources would be
impacted by by development that the
municipality would have to you know bear
and then I was pointed back oh we're
looking at the public water and sewer
but that was that's not enough so I do
appreciate because clearly there are as
listed and enumerated here other impacts
that are going to affect the
municipality and the cost of the
municipality so I will be supporting
this amendment
representative
thank you Mr chair
um I noticed that you left out one
change
uh that your amendment makes which is in
line 24.
uh I believe with the second page where
it omits the section which is Section I
on Conservation Commission and I'm
wondering if that was an intentional
uh change or perhaps an error and if it
it was intentional can you explain your
thinking behind excluding conservation
commissions
um that was intentional it was not
unintentional
um there's probably a few other place
things that I change that I um have not
mentioned one of them the other one was
New Hampshire
Association of regional Planning
Commission in in H I left that out just
personally because I don't believe that
as I said my goal is more a from the
fiscal sense uh my concerns rather than
from the conservation
commission sense so that's why I looked
it up
sure
um and are there no fiscal consequences
to the impact on our environment
there may be but in my amendment I I
excluded that
representing priests
okay
very dyslexic but anyway back to this
amendment
um I agreed with much all that
Representatives as stavis has said about
the need to have a person of
conservation
expertise on this study Commission
because conservation is one of the
important factors in New Hampshire it
plays a vital part in the rural
communities
and it would it makes it's one of the
things that makes New Hampshire what it
is
it's natural beauty and we take the
expertise out of this committee
we're kind of denying this how fact
research base that will not be included
and I think they need to be included
also on the areas of study I was
questioning why you didn't mention
Cemetery sewer
since that's going to be more and more
critical especially if you are
developing at a higher density and
making sure that the municipalities have
the sewer capacity or if they even have
a sewer to handle this thank you
there
yeah
it's there
I believe that's in there representative
priests
[Music]
public water and soon yeah line 20 line
29 stage one
that was already in the existing Bill
representative I didn't change that at
all
representative bro
just a clarification I'm trying to
understand the environmental concerns
since on line 17 it talks about the
commissioner of the Department of
Environmental Services or designee so am
I missing something there during that
conversation
from the amendment it shows that
appointed by the Speaker of the House
that is correct it is on there yes okay
so I'm trying to figure out where the
environmental concerns are in regard to
the commission
representative Reed
so uh understanding that representative
priests might want to answer that
question in a second
um my comment may actually be more to
the underlying bill but since the
sponsor of the amendment brought this
point up I would like to respond to it
which is you know of course all of us
have heard arguments against commissions
and committees and there's so many
studies and we study the studies of the
studies and all of that but I am with my
training as a molecular biologist I am
very much
um in favor of gathering all information
and so I I've never really appreciated
the idea of we shouldn't study anything
really we should study as much as we
possibly can and be make the most
informed decisions that we can possibly
make
um and I don't feel like we should say
sorry to any of us legislators for
having to do the work that we begged our
constituents to send us to go do and
even more so for a speaker any speaker
not just our current one who not only
begs to be elected but then also begs us
to vote for him or her as speaker so
they are asking for that job so I don't
feel bad that they then have to do that
work so I think it's good to study
things and be informed when we make our
decisions my issue with commissions and
study committees comes in what voices
are we amplifying to the exclusion of
what other voices and so I have a
problem with excluding some voices and
taking out some voices like the
conservation
um voice in this scenario because that's
the real issue again Gathering as much
information as possible I think is key
to making the most informed decisions
possible
thank you
microphone representative
uh representative treeleven then Hicks
thank you Mr chair
um I'm gonna
jump on to this Conservation Commission
wagon
from a different point so maybe I'm
bringing up the rear or maybe I'm riding
up front with the coach person but what
I want to say is and my work as a real
estate broker over the years 35 and
counting
I have seen conservation commissions
come into a scenario where a building in
a more urban setting that was adjacent
to a wetlands and this is just one
example there are many
needed to have the Conservation
Commission look at the building and
figure out with the building owner who
wanted to sell the building how it could
be brought
to speed where we were then whatever
year it was in regards to the
regulations and to continue to protect
our environment long story short
Conservation Commission did a great job
of interfacing and interacting with the
Realtors involved the the owner of the
property the people who wanted to buy
the property and made very reasonable
demands as to how the land had to be
handled before they would give it its
approval that building is still there
it's in Portsmouth it's on Islington
road and it has made money for all the
people who have used it and it has
protected
the environment the wetlands that are
behind it by listening to the very
simple
observations that those of us who aren't
schooled in that might not understand
so I'm totally in favor of leaving the
Conservation Commission in I think the
input's really important and and I have
to say I think it has
an economic effect this was probably 25
years ago I think now it has even a
bigger economic effect because they're
not making any more water they're not
making any more soil they're not making
any we're not making any more rocks what
we got is what we got thanks
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman um I'll just make one point to
not believe are those points
um although I support those points uh I
was contacted by a member of the society
for the protection New Hampshire Forest
they would like to be part of this
Representatives priests
thank you Mr chairman
um again I would I echoed the the
statements that have been made by
Senator tree Levin totally again
um and I have worked on study committees
where the conservation
individual professional has played a
significant part
in the discussion and I think they need
to be part of this discussion
second to the question that was raised
by representative Brown
the Department of Environmental
Protection is a great organization they
have great services
conservation is not one of their things
that they do there
they protect our water resources
they you know they help with the sewers
you know infrastructure and air quality
but they don't do conservation
thank you
representative yokella
um for recognizing me this uh
I I don't really understand how the com
the conversation has gone
um this far down the road of
conservation being vital to this
Commission because the commission is
based is is studying the effects of
density
and and the barriers to density so
unless conservation and
conservation is a beneficiary of density
because they have more open land if you
have you know the the property built out
every two acres then there's less land
to conserve
I don't I'm just it it seems like
there's a whole lot of discussion about
what they're bringing to this to the
discussion of the of this
commission there's not a lot of clarity
on what they're bringing to the
discussion of density and how are they
the cause of the of a barrier towards
density or are they
I don't understand how they are
um advising us on what are the barriers
to density like the commission
can can someone that's in favor of that
clarify how they affect density which is
the study of this commission thank you
I'm going to recognize representative
majority next maybe he can address that
in his comment uh thank you Mr chair and
I'm not sure that I that I will but I'll
I'll speak relative to what my
Conservation Commission does in
Northampton where what they're looking
at is the value of land and if we're
talking about the density of of a piece
of property
um not only to talk about the value of
land among many other things they also
talk about easements which allow people
to access that land so if we're talking
about density how do we get to a
valuable piece of land
Conservation Commission is one of the
first places that that the planning
board will go for advice on that and
when you have a community again like
Northampton which is a third in
conservation but we do have the rights
to have conservation subdivisions we
really look at that interplay between
the high the value of the land
the access to that land and how much can
you build upon that land the
Conservation Commission is intimately
involved in all of those aspects so I
think it's a crucial piece of this I'm
not sure that I've answered your
question but it's a reason why I would
really urge this commission to have to
include conservation thank you
representative Gilman
thank you Mr chair to that point about
how density and conservation Works
um if you have open space planning which
we do an Exeter you can have more dense
or you can work out a compromise with
the planning board to have a more dense
development if you put some of the land
into conservation that backs up with
another place that has conservation that
already got density bonus so that's how
Exeter ended up having 30 percent of
gland in conservation so there is there
is a bonus factor and I think that the
conservation
could be should be represented
represented because people don't know
that people in the other groups are not
planners some are
so I I would I would vote against this
amendment for taking that out because
there is a reason for the the offset
between and it would drive if you want
to keep when it's driving in Exeter
density within our downtown because we
can't expand into those areas that have
been put into conservation so I think
that needs to be explained and it has to
have been put on the committee
thank you representative service
thank you Mr chair and not to belabor
this but um for those of us who live in
cities that are already pretty dense the
Conservation Commission is absolutely
vital to guide conversations of of where
one can safely build without impinging
on Wetlands impinging on important
Wildlife corridors and in conservation
commissions are an integral part of
every municipality's master plan so you
can't really get into a conversation
about where are we going to go with
regard to density increasing density in
housing without including the vital
players in the master planning process
so that's one aspect of why the
Conservation Commission representation
is important and I have a question for
the chair if he will allow me
which is if
if the point of the amendment
is or the point the amendment seeks to
make is that there are already two
commission too many commissions studying
too many things why doesn't the
amendment eliminate the commission
altogether
I would be more than happy to answer
that and again it was my
desire would be to eliminate the
commission and not even begin the
commission to begin with
um sometimes we
do things to try to get along
if you if you would and this would be my
amendment is an attempt to
make things get along a little bit
better like I said I have no problem if
uh if this amendment fails of making uh
we will make an itl motion on the whole
bill
um if we need to and then we'll go to
the floor with that so as I said with
this with this amendment I'm more than
happy to vote for it mainly because it
includes the fiscal issues that are my
issues if we do if we're gonna
you know vote this down just because of
a conference Conservation Commission
um like I say I'm more than happy to do
an itl on it
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman I don't really know how this
works so I'll ask the question it seems
that many of us are stuck on the
Conservation Commission elimination from
you know in the amendment uh if the
sponsor were willing to add that back in
and we could pass the amendment how does
that work
that would require an amendment to the
amendment
uh which we're probably not going to
have a whole lot of time for the other
option would be a motion of retain
or we could also make a motion to
um
recess this particular executive session
to a future date
which will probably be happening anyway
on another bill that we're going to be
discussing soon
those would be the options
follow-up representative Hicks thank you
um so if if you would be um
will need to accept that motion I would
make the motion to recess
uh that well no
um the motion for recess would have to
come for me
um
let me think about that motion to recess
further comments yeah we got some more
down there representative
thank you Mr chair I wanted to uh go
back and directly address representative
yokella's uh question slash comment
um and I think I understood where he was
coming from in his the angle when he was
talking about the conservation uh
commissions and the idea that
conservation benefits from increased
density I think what you were trying to
say is
we increase conservation to the extent
that we concentrate populations so
increasing density and already dense
popular and are you dense areas rather
than non-dense areas but increased
density for the most part requires
increasing density in non-dense areas
and that's where we run into issues
where conservation really is a barrier
to increased density because for example
current use requires 10 acres
so you can't seven does it change I
apologize I'm not I'm not a member of
this committee
uh thank you but also from a general
conservation standpoint
um people who are interested in Wildlife
Conservation something I do know about
uh that uh the idea the principle is to
have as large areas of conservation as
possible for wildlife populations it's
more beneficial to have if you have the
same number of Acres it's more
beneficial to have all of that
contiguous rather than separated into
smaller Parcels so because that is a
basic conservation principle
conservation does actually present a
barrier to to increased density
I greatly appreciate the appreciate the
correction representative
no I appreciate it for the comments
so Representatives this was my thought
we do have to
uh have disposition of this particular
Amendment
uh if it were to pass
an amendment could be made
and the this excess session could be
recessed to a future date I just went to
check to see which time which day room
is going to be available we will be
coming back
either the 17th or the 24th briefly
hopefully
so if this were to pass
and I called a recess somebody would be
able to make that
Amendment to the amendment
I will leave it there for the comments
representative priests
uh Mr chairman just a point of
clarification would it also be possible
for you to withdraw your emotion on the
amendment and then make the motion to
retain this bill to a future date to
correct the amendment and add the
conservation I could I I'm not going to
withdraw the motion we can
and it wouldn't be a retain I mean we
can retain this retain
is a much longer rather than recess I'm
just if we recess this particular
executive session we can do it to a
specific date
either next week or the week after is
what I'm getting at
a follow-up at that time if the
amendment does pass
without the language
um
never mind thank you
further further comments questions
seeing none will ask the clerk to call a
role on this amendment
SB 47 Amendment 2023 1677h
uh Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes representative Salas yes
representative Keller
yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Owen yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes
Representatives Davis no
Representative titro no
representative tree eleven no
representative gentleman no
representative majority
no
uh representative now
representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks no
representative Reed no
representative Priest No
and chairman
sorry
yes okay I'm sorry it's a tight
promotion representative
uh 10 to 10.
representative how are you have a motion
I actually had a question
what what are the options at this point
options are
OTP uh itl
retain
representative status
I make a motion about to pass
do we have a second per episode
David priests
do we have comments on the OTP
representative yokella
thank you if the OTP passed
um
and
uh uh in between now and the
um
in between now and the uh the floor
an amendment very similar to the
amendment that we just did not pass very
closely
um that might had have uh been more
supported by this committee could be
offered as a floor Amendment on the
floor and Achieve that same
goal as the recessing to a future date
is my understanding of that correctly
and correct I believe you're correct if
we recess to his later date it could be
done within committee
if it
um passes OTP it will go to the floor
and then a floor Amendment would be
needed
is my understanding representative Brown
Mr chair what's the barrier to recessing
this to a later date now
there's no motion you have to
is it is it only you that can do that
could you state the question again
representative uh what's the barrier to
just recessing this to a later date for
our committee there is none except we
have a motion on the floor okay thank
you so much yes good question
thank you Mr chair
in response to what representative Brown
just asked would be my understanding it
was my understanding and please correct
me if I'm wrong that had we passed this
amendment we could recess the entire
kitten caboodle come back and amend it
again just in committee under recess we
didn't pass the amendment so
so we're done
with the amendment as it stands as far
as I can see although I could be wrong
no you're correct thank you you're
correct okay
unless it's brought up representative
yokello was talking about bringing it up
as a floorman no I I understand that and
I thought oh excuse me thank you yeah
anybody else uh representative Hicks
just quickly thank you Mr chairman um I
do actually agree with you in principle
on the number of commissions and really
the responsibility of us who are
legislators to get together for things
that we are passionate about I think
that is a better approach than forcing
people to sit on commissions uh that
being said I believe this is something
that has
existed previously and so I don't have a
problem supporting this
because of the issues and because it has
existed previously but I I am fully in
support of
reducing the number of commissions that
we have
representative
thank you just to tack on to the
procedural conversation so even though
we did not pass this amendment that we
were just discussing if the chair chose
to recess it's not emotion it's it's
just something a chair can do we would
have we you all really you all would
have time to um get a new Amendment
together that might be a compromise
Amendment amongst leadership for example
so it's still I think would behoove the
committee to do that and perhaps if the
chair was willing the motion could be
withdrawn
well to do what you suggested
representative Reed it would require the
motion to be withdrawn otherwise we have
to dispose of the current motion
representative Hicks one more comment um
other than the elimination of the
Conservation Commission I think that the
amendment was a better Amendment the
reason I didn't vote for it was because
of that so actually like
the amendment with the conservation
better than the current bill
just for
just to bring that point out
thank you representative
I'd like to thank representative Hicks
for that comment and I feel exactly the
same way
and would be willing
to think about this carefully
if if the chair was willing to
compromise on the Conservation
Commission
I might be willing to amend my emotion
or withdraw my emotion
depending on how we can work that out
procedurally
it would require a YouTuber withdraw
your motion and whoever seconded it and
I believe we could
work out what's
representative Hicks is suggesting
representative stavis then I withdraw my
motion
thank you representative representative
priest I will also withdraw my second
but I do have a question a procedural uh
question if we make a motion to
um recess this bill to a later date
I'm sorry it's not emotion it's it's
something I can just call you can just
call yourself okay
that's my question thank you with that
in mind everybody hold off for two
minutes
take lunch
and then come back
all right so
um
Jamie is not here so I can't I I need to
clarify which day
so she's coming right back okay so let's
just
talk for a few minutes and
representative save us
so I'm going to take this opportunity to
just say how much very much I appreciate
being on this particular committee
and have been on this committee for
going on five years now how much I
appreciate the chair and the vice chair
and all of the leadership and members
for the work we do to achieve what is
largely a bipartisan consensus on most
of the issues that confront us and I'm
just I'm very grateful for all of that
and I just want to thank you
thank you representative Reed
I would like to take this moment to
apologize to the deputy ranking member
for repeatedly mispronouncing his name
these many years since he was first
elected uh pronouncing it with indeed
four syllables instead of three in in
being substituting on this committee has
taught me the error of my ways
representative Reed I believe you are
actually correct it's majori majority I
have indeed Mr chair been saying
maggiori these many years
representative
well thank you
thank you Mr chair I just while we're
chatting and hearing about a vacation in
Italy
softball he says hahaha
um I won't be here from the 16th through
the 23rd uh just to let you all know so
someone will need to substitute me I'll
try to recruit someone who lives up to
representative powers and
representatives Davis's standards
because they are good high standards and
uh I wish you all the best I'll bring
you back some sunshine from Disneyland
what
uphold uphold
really okay
okay so uh
the executive
session on 20 uh no
SB 47
will be recessed till 10 a.m on the 24th
of May
okay
so
I'm not going to hammer it down because
that's just in recess we have one bill
left so
here's the options I'm going to see a
show of hands what we want to do
this is going to be today this is going
to be another bill that I will
recess until that same day so we're
going to have two bills to go over I
think we're gonna have a lot of
discussion on this one I'd prefer to see
that discussion as much as we can do
today I know there's been a lot of work
behind the scenes at least from our side
um this there's issues with the bill
that we want to clean up if it's to go
forward so
not sure how long the discussion on that
is going to take so the question is do
you want to break for lunch now or do
you want to push through
on this last bill and then call it a day
is there anybody who wants to break for
lunch right now
I see three hand uh Representatives
Davis
what are we trying to accomplish in
having the conversation today as opposed
to when we recess to
because I think there's going to be a
lot of discussion regardless of what the
um what the bill ends up looking like if
there's an amendment or whatever I think
it's a very
bill with potential conflict so I'd like
to get as much of that out of the way as
we can today at least get everybody's
opinion on it if you'd prefer to just do
it all at once next time we can also do
that but
I'd
am I seeing people want to do it all at
once rather than today I would prefer
that yeah you would okay well we can do
that so I am not going to open up
Deborah
um Mr chairman thank you I'm not sure
but
it seems to me that I'd like to see a
consensus of how many members have
actually
reviewed the Salient sections of Title
VII of the U.S code relative to this
bill because if you don't know what that
it says then discussion is going to fall
flat on its face so what we will do
based on the comments I'm going to ask
um
before I recess it I'm going to ask
Deborah because she's been doing an
extremely
large amount of work and research on
this
we'll have two weeks before we come back
and actually exec the bill we will exec
it unless somebody decides they want to
retain it but I do plan on executing
these last two bills on the 24th so at
that whatever information Deborah that
you have on that that anybody else has
use the next two weeks wisely
I would have preferred to actually got
some discussion going today but if the
will of the group is do it all at once
we can do it that way also
representative priests and I would also
encourage any
of the members on this committee if they
have amendments
to share it with the members prior to
the meeting so we're prepared to talk
about them and to deal with it at that
time
I I would agree
um and I think representative priests at
least the three amendments I was
involved with you had in your hands over
a week ago I sent to the entire
committee if you didn't receive them
it's because you've given us a bad email
address but I sent those off at least a
week ago
so I I I try to do that represent a
priest because there's nothing worse
than I hate than getting an amendment
the day before uh eight on SB 222 OLS
didn't complete that simple one line
um
that I sent them until yesterday
afternoon when I landed from Rome and I
immediately sent it out to everybody as
soon as I got it so I I attempt to do
that and I would ask everybody to do
that as you know as soon as you have a
Amendment also you know if don't don't
wait till the last minute
uh till don't wait a weekend six days
from now to start doing the research or
whatever I'd ask again Deborah to get
your research out maybe send it to me or
Diane and then we can float it out to
everybody in the committee
representative Brown
uh Mr chairman would it be possible for
the minority and majority side to
discuss what their major concerns with
the bill are before we recess
just an overview maybe what the issues
are so that as as I research this I can
be more thoughtful in in my approach to
the information that I'm researching to
understand a little bit better view to
be more open to maybe some of the
concerns that was the point of my
statement before was whether or not we
wanted to begin a discussion today or
do it all at once later I'm
ambivalent I would prefer to have it out
start now but it appears the majority
would rather wait and do it all at once
representative kale is there anything
stopping representative Brown from
meeting with his colleagues over lunch
and talking
there is not
similar to
the need for commissions
where people should be able to get
together and organize what they wish to
do rather than say Hey you go and do all
the research on this commission yes you
can do that it's a very good point
representative Cahill representative I'm
sorry
representative
representative machiotti
I love him desperately Representatives
thank you rep um thank you Mr chair
um
my current status has made me realize
that we are all human beings made of
Flesh and Blood maybe I should write a
song about that we've been here since 10
30 doing our work and candidly I for one
am cooked
I'd be happy to have lunch with you and
talk about it maybe even another day but
I prefer not to stay here in committee
and force you all
for however long to talk more right now
I I yield to my humanity and to my
colleagues from Italy
foreign
we're just going round and round now on
what we're gonna do so uh representative
Edward I'll give you the last word and
thank you Mr chairman
just to give you an idea
um in trying to
address some of the concerns in
opposition testimony and and things I
was seeing that just didn't seem right
you literally have to sit down with the
three sections of title eight which are
1357 and 1226 and you have to look at
the bills side by side and try to make
sense of what the bill is trying to do
versus what federal law says
and then go to the objections that were
raised especially that of
um the bill forcing or coercing or
requiring
um local law enforcement and state law
enforcement to enforce immigration
detainers
I spent 40 hours looking for where that
is in federal law and I can't find it
so if you familiarize yourself with
those sections that specifically say
federal state or local law enforcement
in those three sections isolate them
understand them as they relate to the
bill will have a fantastic discussion
thank you representative Elward so what
I'm going to ask you to do is in a brief
one-page summary
outline all the issues that you believe
we need addressing I know you have been
talking with the sponsors about a
potential Amendment if that comes to
pass that's fine also but please send
what you believe we should all be
looking at to Diane representative power
sorry and we will get that out to the
entire
committee okay so with that I will
recess SB 132 to May 24th at 10 A.M
also
are there any further questions or
comments
seeing none we will see everybody on the
24th representative Hicks
after could you come and discuss thank
you all right we'll save everybody on
the 24th